Kylie Jenner has got babies on the brain
baby okay living on in an Instagram post
celebrating Stormy's father Travis Scott
the 21 year old mama didn't leave much
to the imagination it's just so crazy
Kylie shared this sweet montage of
family photos on Tuesday along with the
caption happy happy birthday
let around and have another baby now
this isn't the first time the youngest
Jenner has been blatant AF about her
desire to have more kids with Travis
earlier this month
Kylie instagrammed these racy snaps of
her straddling the rapper while enjoying
a vacation I just love my body and in
March she opened up to Germany's
interview magazine about motherhood and
getting preggers again quote I do want
more kids but I do not have any plans in
the near future to have children right
now you gotta do things without me
yeah you know in recent weeks the
parents of one-year-old stormy have been
weathering cheating rumors directed at
Scott he's denied the claims and an
insider previously told ET that the pair
is doing really well and although
they've had their recent issues they've
moved past that and are moving forward
the source added quote Travis and Kylie
are a young couple first-time parents
and this is all new to them they are
taking each day as an opportunity to
grow and learn as a couple they call
each other husband and wife are they
married engaged what's the situation you
know I'm literally me to ask her that is
gonna be my next question on our group
chat we were chatting on the way over
here and I think we just all think like
that's like you know what they call each
other
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]